Well. Hello everyone, producer Pat here, filling
in for David today. Uh, at least for now,
at least for the first part of the show, David
is of course at home resting. He had appendicitis,
had to get surgery yesterday, early in the
morning. Uh, he should be back next week.
He's in good spirits. He's feeling okay. Uh,
but he does feel as though a part of him is
missing, which does make sense after getting
one's appendix taken out. But we have to get
into the news because the news waits for no
one. Uh, and what I want to talk about today
is how Trump held a joint press conference
with the Finnish president, Salin and histo.
They talked about the normal stuff at first
trade security economics. They both had their
prepared statements. Uh, but everyone realizes
that it's sort of a charade because when it's
time to ask questions, no reporters actually
going to ask about us finish relations.
They're going to ask about the topics of the
day. They're going to ask about the things
that they want to ask about. And right now
the topic on everyone's mind is impeachment.
And the call that president Trump had with
the Ukrainian president back in July. And
really at this point, it's not even a question
over whether the president committed a crime.
It's more a question about how many crimes
that president Trump commit and what were
the severity of those crimes. And are we as
a people going to hold them accountable either
by way of a Congress impeaching Trump Trump,
or by way of the voters voting him out in
2020. So all that stuff is of course still
left to be decided. But the press conference
was a total mess. It was Trump going on and
on about how this is just the latest witch
hunt and how everyone's out to get him.
He talked about shifty, Adam Schiff. Uh, Adam
Schiff is of course the head of the U S intelligence
committee, uh, in the house. And you know,
calling a Jewish person shifty definitely
has some antisemitic undertones, but that's
the sort of thing that we can kind of come
to expect from Trump at this point. Uh, but
what I found most peculiar of all was how
Trump would try to be alpha over the Finnish
president at times, but then other times he
would hide behind the Finnish president. So
like what would happen would be Trump would
get a question, he would ramble on and on,
take control of the floor, not let the finish
president talk. And then whenever he would
get a question from a reporter that he didn't
like, he would say, why aren't you asking
the British presidents something? We have
a guest here. It would be rude not to ask
the finished president something. Uh, so let
me show you one example of that and then we'll
come back.
Okay. What's your second question? But you
shouldn't be answering, asking two questions.
You're gonna want to answer. Do me a favor,
ask one of the, I will finish. John. Jack,
you want to ask this question? One of the
Finnish president. Can I come back to you?
Because I think you'll want to, we'll talk
later. Sure. Well, it sounds like it might
be good question. Let me see if I liked the
question. Go ahead. Maybe for the first time
in three years. I'll have a good question
and I'll love it
and then here's Trump doing the exact same
thing again. A sprinkled in this time with
some fake news. This is all a hoax stuff that
we've come to expect from Trump.
What are we, go ahead and ask the question,
sir, was, what did you want president Selenski
to do about president vice president Biden
and his son Hunter? Are you talking to me?
Yeah, it was just a follow up of what I just
asked you sir. You ready? We have the president
of Finland. Ask him a question. I have one
form. I just wanted to follow up on the one
that I asked you, which did you hear me? Did
you hear me ask him a question? I will, but
I'm giving you a long answer. Ask this gentleman
a question. Don't be rude. No sir. I don't
want to be rude. I just wanted you to have
a chance to answer the question that I asked
you. Everything. It's a whole hoax and you
know who's playing into the hopes, people
like you and the fake news media that we have
in this country.
And I say in many cases that corrupt media
because you corrupt much of the media in this
country is not just fake, it's corrupt. And
you have some very fine people to great journalists,
great reporters, but it to a large extent,
it's corrupt and it's fake. Ask the president
of Finland to question place. Okay, I'll move
on now, mr president, in your opening remarks,
you said to president Trump that you had been
to some museums today and that you respected
the U S democracy and encouraged him to continue
it. Are you concerned that that's not happening?
And my second question to you, sir, is the
WTO rule today in favor of the United States
saying that the United States can now impose
tariffs on European goods because of illegal
subsidies against Airbus was a big win for
the United States, right? It wasn't the headwinds
with other presidents, did you? But we're
having a lot of wins at the WTO since I started
I think 10 or 15 years ago. But excuse me,
it'll winds are now because they think I don't
like the WTO and they want to make sure I'm
happy because all of those countries, we're
ripping off the United States for many years.
They know that I'm wise to it. We've had a
lot of winds. This was a $7 billion win. Not
bad. So the question, sir, is, if you're concerned
that the president,
I absolutely love it, and yes, those body
language, they're like, he's pointing, trying
to get a word in and it's not like he's being
like a total pushover or anything, but he's
being deferential. And I think that makes
all the sense in the world. One, because you
know, he's a guest in a foreign country, but
I think it more so has to do with the fact
that it's there. He realizes that Trump has
power over him. Uh, the U S is of course,
a much bigger country than Finland. And if
Trump is upset with their leader, uh, he could
retaliate against them. And he's done that
before with smaller countries. We saw him,
uh, temporarily pull aid from Ukraine. So
maybe the Finnish president doesn't want a
similar thing to happen to him. Of course,
the U S doesn't give Finland financial aid.
Uh, but you know, something, something similar
could of course happen.
So this was the press conference. It's a total
gong show. But Hey, that's the a, that's the
America that we live in
in 2019.